تدخين باضرار اقل وخال من التبق خيار في
المستقبل القريب سيكون امام المدخنين في
السعوديه هذا ما يسعى اليه صندوق
الاستثمارات العامه عبر شركه بدائل التي
اعلن بالامس تاسيسها بالتزامن مع اليوم
العالمي للامتناع عن تعاطي الطبخ حيث تهدف
الشركه المنشاه الى تقديم بدائل خاليه من
التبغ واقل ضررا وذلك من خلال تصنيع
وتوزيع منتجات مبتكره للحد من انتشار
التدخين على الصعيد المحلي فان منتجات
بدائل ستساهم في مساعده قرابه مليون شخص
على الاقلاع عن التدخين اي ما يمثل نسبه
25% من المدخنين داخل السعوديه كما ستوفر
المنتجات اكثر من سته مليارات ريال سنويا
من نفقات الرعايه الصحيه بحلول 2022
واوضحت الشركه التابعه لصندوق الاستثمارات
العامه ان المنتجات التي ستحمل شعارها في
المستقبل القريب سيتم تصنيعها محليا وفق
اعلى معايير الجوده والسلامه وتطمح شركه
بدائل في توسيع نطاقها للوصول الى الاسواق
الاقليميه واستحداث فرص عمل فضلا عن تحقيق
المستهدفات استراتيجيه الصندوق لرفع مستوى
جوده الحياه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات